let's play a trading game okay so you
two can play this trading game so here's
the deal it's very simple I'm gonna give
you $100 I'm not actually but yeah I'm
gonna give you $100 and you can offer
some of it to your partner in the game
but the rule is if she says no you don't
get anything and neither does she
and you only get to make one offer so
okay here's your hundred dollars how
much you can offer her
40 ok would you take 40 okay now that's
interesting very good that's perfect
okay so first of all the classic
economist would say you should offer her
a dollar why
because she might as well take a dollar
because she gets a dollar yeah and you
want to maximize your own return so you
get 99 dollars it's like
what happens when you do that what
happens is that is never what people do
they usually offer approximately 50%
yeah what's and and if they don't then
the other person refuses yeah now then
you might think well let's say you
matched a rich person and a poor person
and you said okay give the rich person
100 and they offer the poor person a
dollar what does the poor person say you
think well yeah yeah I need the dollar
State they say no go to hell I'm not
doing it because and they're more likely
the poor person is more likely to refuse
the lower offer than a rich person is
completely running completely contrary
to the predictions of classical
economists you play that game across the
world it's pretty much 50/50 and that's
so interesting because it's another
example of that emergent ethic it's like
well part of the reason you'd say no and
why no is correct is because you don't
play one trading game you play a
lifetime of trading games and the right
answer to the question of how to play a
lifetime of trading games is to not
settle for less than 50% money you could
also make a case that if you're the
giver rather than receiver if you're
playing an iterated game you might want
to offer $60 $60 because especially if
your reputation is being broadcast
because let's say your goal isn't to get
forty dollars which is what you'd be
left if you offered 60 your goal is to
let everybody know that if they play
with you you give them 60 and you get 40
and then what happens is like well let's
take a vote on who wants to play with
who it's like you want to play with the
person who offers the attend or do you
want to play with the person who offers
you 60 and then the person who's a
little more generous than reciprocal you
know 50 50 would be reciprocal maybe you
should arrow on the side of generosity
why easily easy people will line up to
play with you so then the question is do
you want to win the game or do you want
to win the set of games right and I
think I think there's rules that govern
the set of all possible games and it's
the rules that govern the set of all
possible games that constitutes
something like an emergent ethic so
anyway so that's a very useful thing to
know it's a very useful thing to know it
is can you give a couple quick ones of
those potential universal ethics that
govern the set of games well I think I
think that's the big one I think I think
the big one is you approximate
reciprocity but it would be better it'd
be better if you can figure out how to I
think you its receptor esse prosody with
erring on the side of generosity because
there's just no downside to that in an
iterated game it's like I'm gonna borrow
what I do when I grade papers with
students for example as I grade them and
then I had 5% it's like well maybe I
made a mistake so I'll err on the side
of generosity right and why not do that
in your reciprocal interactions that
doesn't mean you're letting people take
advantage of you right it's not a matter
of a weakness in your negotiating
strategy because there's no excuse for
that that's just that's a losing game
not but if you could take 50% or 70% and
you decide to be generous it's like well
you still have to be awake so that
you're not in messed about with by
people who are a little bit on the
psychopathic end you know you don't want
to be foolish about it but
reciprocal plus generous that's a hell
of a good start